the freeman I direct the Foreign Policy
Institute and I'm delighted to welcome
you to this evenings a Foreign Policy
Institute conversation with author
Michele looker
she has just produced a her latest an
excellent book the grain rye know how to
recognize and act on the obvious dangers
we ignore I want it's wonderful to
welcome Michelle to sice I am so
grateful to her for putting sice on the
on as a stop on her book tour I had the
pleasure of traveling with Michelle in
the UAE last fall and heard about this
book and so have been it been
anticipating it and it it's an exciting
read I think she has through asking the
question why we ignore crises that we
can see coming until they're they
literally Stampede us I think she's got
a new paradigm for thinking about risk
and I'm excited to hear her discuss some
of her ideas this evening this book
follows two others that III read the one
on Haitians and Dominicans that I had
and I had not put that together I didn't
realize when I met you last fall that
you were the author of that that
exquisitely written book she also wrote
a marvelous book on immigration that
asks why we get immigration so wrong
even though our prosperity depends on
our getting it right she's a prolific
writer she's a just has had a
distinguished career in journalism and
has also received numerous awards for
her leadership including young global
leaders award through the World Economic
Forum and she has also been recognized
as a Guggenheim Fellow and has been the
president of the World Policy Institute
among other leadership roles welcome
Michelle and leading our conversation
this evening is is dr. Jeff Leonard dr.
Leonard is the CEO of the global
environment fund which is a private
equity fund that invests in I in growth
companies that focus on renewable energy
an environmental
and as well as energy efficiency he is
chairman of a number of boards including
the board of the Washington Monthly he
also serves on the board of New America
and he himself as a prolific writer he's
produced five books including the
award-winning pollution in the struggle
for the world product so we're very
grateful to have him lead the
conversation this evening and I hope
that all of you will stay and continue
it at the end of their discussion and
the Q&A we're going to have a raffle and
raffle off some books that Michelle's
publisher was kind enough to make
available to us so she will sign books
and I hope you'll enjoy the reception
and discuss the ideas that we are going
to talk about this evening so welcome
thank you very much everyone for coming
it's great for me as a Washington person
and to be here at SycE also I should say
it at GE F over the years we've hired a
number of sized people especially people
who have done both the finance program
saya warden and the site and the size
program here because the worldliness of
a sy student and the precision of a
warden student is what we really need a
GE F we have to have that the big policy
pictures and so on but also the the
ability to do it with with really
serious financial skills Michelle I'm
very fortunate because I've been able to
as a sort of an idol friend of
Michelle's we get together periodically
we email often about ideas and so I've
been able to be present since the early
parts of this the gestation of this book
and it's very very exciting it's an
extraordinarily well-written book and I
don't usually say that about policy
books or books like this but it's very
well written it has it unfolds in so
many profound layers and will only
scratch the surface of the gray Rhino
syndrome today in our in our
conversation but it you really could
apply we're going to try to keep it to
foreign policy
but the book itself some of the richest
parts of the book are on corporate
behavior and on domestic policy and even
down to individual behavior and
political settings and so on but so well
I think it's really going to be fun
today because will elicit from you we
hope ideas about how to apply this in in
foreign policy the concept I'm going to
let Michelle define for you and then
tell us a little bit how she found her
way to it I just want to say that about
30-something years ago as a graduate
student at the London School of
Economics I was traveling in what was
then Yugoslavia and I kept a journal and
as a studying political economic systems
and I really wanted to understand
socialist economics and what was going
on with reform and the socialist systems
so travelled all over you Slavia I kept
a journal
I wrote prolifically about it I wrote
some articles and so on but one thing
stands out in that Journal is still have
it today it said everybody I talked to
hates everyone else and I said this
country is going to blow sky-high when
Tito dies so that's kind of the gray
Rhino anybody who was present there
could see could feel that this was a
country only held together by the force
of one man but 1980 of course he died
and then we've had Bosnia we had all
these horrors and terrible situations
but that greater honor was so apparent
and yet nobody talked about it so to me
that is the epitome of what what
Michelle is going to talk about today so
I'd like to start Michelle maybe with
you telling us just finding the grey
rhino and then after you do that tell us
how you found it sure and I have to say
praise from from from Jeff for a book is
is really something else because he's
quite an accomplished writer himself so
so thank you for that
so the grey rhino is something that's
really big it's coming at you it's got a
big horn it's it's really dangerous it's
as if you think of the elephant in the
room the
obvious thing that nobody wants to talk
about and that we take for granted that
nobody's gonna do anything about but
it's just kind of standing still and you
get the elephant in the room together
with the Black Swan a book that came out
about ten years ago saying that we
needed to pay more attention to highly
improbable unpredictable high-impact
events that as an individual it's hard
to predict but as a group happened much
more than than we think so you get the
else in the room together with the Black
Swan and the love child is the gray
Rhino it's it's something that's highly
probable it's predictable within reason
of course you might no not know every
single contour of the detail but it's
going to happen it's a matter of when
not if unless somebody does something
pretty big and dramatic to deal with it
but it's not getting the attention that
it needs
and this might not mean that it's
completely ignored but it's something
that's certainly not being dealt with
properly it's certainly not resolved and
the way it came to the the Rhino was
looking at sovereign debt crises in a
former life I was a financial journalist
writing about emerging markets debt and
was fascinated by Argentina and as many
of you remember in in 2001 it had a
pretty dramatic falling apart about nine
months before that there was a proposal
that went around Wall Street some some
very very smart bankers and academics
saw the direction things were going
there was no way Argentina was going to
be able to pay its debt if it kept going
the same direction so they said look
here's a proposal let's write down 30%
of this debt and that's what it will
take to to turn the situation around and
Argentina wanted to save face so they
said no and the banks were doing all
sorts of crazy restructurings that were
very very expensive and weren't really
solving the problem so it didn't happen
of course nine months later Argentina
collapsed and the banks lost 70% of face
value instead of 30% which yeah that
idea of 30% versus 70 percent was a
pretty clear example of a stitch in time
saves
to me in fast-forward 10 years to 2011
and Greece is having the same dynamic
happening and in this case it threatens
the entire European Union and I wrote a
paper about that for for the New America
Foundation saying basically Greece you
can learn from Argentina's example and
if you don't the consequences are gonna
be bad and it went right down to to the
last minute I think they worth they were
already half way off the cliff and
people got together and pulled them back
off the edge the private creditors and
Greece came to an agreement that it was
not perfect and not everything was
solved but it certainly helped keep
Greece from defaulting and in turn
helped the European Union from from
falling apart and so I started asking
myself what's the difference what's the
difference between Greece and Argentina
what's the difference between people who
see this this big scary thing coming at
them and do something and the ones who
don't you say that it's really not about
weak signals so in both of those cases
the signals were there it's about weak
perception or weak action to the to the
signals and and I presume that's kind of
how one way you would distinguish a gray
Rhino from a from a Black Swan but
there's one breathless paragraph early
in your book after you've defined it
where you sort of say both many of the
biggest intractable challenges we face
in this world today are gray rhinos and
you it's it is breathless its impending
climate change unsustainable debt levels
anemic economic growth rates rapid and
profound changes in labor market
dynamics widening income disparities
youth unemployment you know on and on
and on so we know of course that as Karl
Popper said that a theory that explains
everything can't explain anything so I
want you to help because since this is
early in the book the whole rest of the
book describes why it doesn't explain
everything but take us through the broad
sort of stages of
recognising and dealing with it with a
gray Rhino of that crisis and and do
also help me because there's one great
point where you say Black Swan is a
crash of grey rhinos now luckily I had
read the part of the book that said a
great Rhino group is actually called a
crash so so but exactly why is us behind
every Black Swan and then tell us how
you recognize the Black Swan distinguish
it and in cope with it
sure well when you see a lot of obvious
things coming together they often when
they meet you might not be able to
predict exactly how they meet or exactly
what the consequences are but it's a
combination of predictable things coming
together the 2008 financial crisis is
just a classic example of that you had
the the subprime crisis you had
questionable uses of derivatives you had
loose supervision of banks you had a lot
of reckless behavior at you also had a
lot of warnings you know a few months
before for everything went down
Christine Lagarde came out and said look
we're facing a financial tsunami if you
do a nexus search of news stories at the
time and references to you know crisis
subprime mortgages credit default swaps
it's pretty clear that yes we saw it
coming despite what so many people have
said in in hindsight and the Black Swan
had just come out at the time and
everyone was talking about you know
Black Swan and financial crisis and oh
this is a Black Swan nobody saw it
coming even though people did and I felt
that they misused the Black Swan concept
a little bit because first of all it's
improbable and unpredictable so the
minute you can actually see it coming
and imagine that it's happening it's
definitely not a Black Swan anymore but
then on the flip side using almost
perfectly opposite logic you have people
after something happened who would say
oh well that was a Black Swan perfectly
unpredictable unforeseeable and 2008
really was a crash of grey rhinos I
think that
certainly even people who saw lots of
elements of that happening probably
didn't quite have the sense of exactly
how extensive the damage was going to be
but a lot of people knew it wasn't going
to be good I was living in New York City
at the time and I had an apartment that
I bought a few years earlier and it had
almost doubled in value and it's a very
small example but I I sold my apartment
and I think there are some other people
who made much bigger bets on the fact
that things were not going to keep going
the direction that they were so the way
you described it though it's almost as
if people at the beginning stages he's
talked about denial and then there's a
modeling phase especially and sometimes
that's benign people just don't want to
admit it and sometimes this more
negative you have a lot of examples of
how institutions systematically fail or
don't allow people to call these things
detention and I just wanted to give you
one example that's so striking about
2008 I was a chairman of the board of
emerging markets private equity
Association at the time and my board was
filled with some of the smartest
investor people you know on the planet
and we had an off-the-record dinner or
one night here in Washington DC with the
chief economist of Standard & Poor's in
2007 and some of the people on our board
were just behind closed doors they were
going what the hell is in this junk
you're rating what and they just
pilloried him the whole night and the
guy just basically said honestly we
don't know we're just we're as worried
as you are you know there were all these
comments that made you really aware
these institutions were where they were
just praying it would go away that like
that grey rhino we're praying it's gonna
turn the other way and not come our way
but sooner or later you have to reach
the stage we we spawned and deal with it
so help us out on that how did 2008 out
of it unfold that we tried to deal with
or do we did well well you know I think
that the ESPY example is is a very good
one there are a lot of people who didn't
know what was going on there there were
certainly a lot of journalists who wrote
about things
this denial is very interesting it's
it's the first stage and when I started
thinking about this denial of course the
first thing I did was go and buy a copy
of Elisabeth kubler-ross s book on death
and dying everybody knows about the the
five stages of grief and she had said
that it's a it should be a temporary
phase it's it's self protective it gives
you enough of a cushion that you can
start absorbing what's happening because
if you absorb it all at once it's just
too much and a lot of people will freak
out and break down and that was
interesting to me and I think some of
them some of the psychological
mechanisms that humans have for dealing
with problems are that denial but we
also set up decision-making systems and
there are also some unconscious things
that we do spend a lot of time looking
at denial and some of the the cognitive
biases that we have to get in the way
one of the biggest ones has to do with
the decision-making structures we set up
a group thing which is that when you get
a lot of people who are similar have
similar perspectives local I'd come from
the same places whatever measure of
similarity you want to use when one
person around the table says something
it's much more likely that you just sees
all the heads nod all the way around the
table and it becomes very difficult to
say something that is not what people
want to hear and I think that's
certainly something that happens in
markets and we're very very tempted to
think that the the party is just going
to keep going on and nobody's gonna take
the punchbowl away but it's inevitable I
mean I look back at that Charles
Kindleberger and his work on financial
crises is you know some of the people
who made this proposal on Argentina in
in 2001 were very much fans of his I
feel like anyone who had ever read
Charles Kindleberger
had to have recognized that and you know
of course you know rereleased his his
classic book recently so so first this
stage there is denial there are other
reasons I think there are a lot of
people who take advantage of this human
tendency towards denial of things that
we don't want to hear you actually got
the the monkeys the scene
we'll hear no evil speak no evil monkeys
you get the the ostrich with the head in
the sand it's this wonderful menagerie
hanging out with the with the black
right now with the grey rhinos and black
swans and then I'll fit in the room but
once you go it once you realize that
people are so susceptible to it you can
you can manipulate that you look at the
the tobacco companies you look at some
of the testimony that's been coming out
about the oil companies that that knew
inside very well what the risks were and
what we're going to happen and really
concealed that and so there's a certain
sort of manufactured denial that we can
we can either take advantage of or we
can be aware of and in question much
more actively white wire weak denying
this in wishful thinking in wishful
thinking just went away be a lot better
than for me to have to fess up yeah very
much so and I think that culture is is
like that you know you you look at
income equality inequality say and you
look at the people who who look up to
certain candidates you know millionaires
billionaires you know very wealthy
business people you look at the debates
over taxes you look at the the debates
over trying to trying to address this
problem of income equality inequality
which is affecting growth which is
helping to create the the poisonous
political climate that we have and a lot
of people don't want to make some of the
hard decisions even people who would
benefit from them because I think I
could someday you know have a big shiny
building with my name on it
you um cite the rule of one of my old
professors really darn Bush when you say
that the crisis takes much longer
incoming than you think and then happens
much faster than you think and this is a
challenge in in markets and in financial
markets this could never be a hedge fund
manager because there are so many times
when I'm right but it takes three years
to be right I remember in the 1990s we
went to our investors in the private
equity and we said we we think the US
stock market is completely and totally
overvalued you know in blah blah blah
blah
and they and you know two years later
three years later they were still saying
to me they're out you know the private
bar I mean public markets are
outperforming you by two hundred and 80
basis points you know every year and and
we were sure they were overnight but it
was way too early so how how do you deal
with that when you arrive you see this
crisis so early but others don't or
they're not ready to act or their
institutions aren't ready to hear you
hear you you know like we've heard so
many stories from 2008 yeah it's it's
very common and in many cases it's it's
a matter of when but exactly when that's
a little little niggling you know devil
on your shoulder that's where I think
you need to come into understanding some
of the the later phases of a gray rhino
oh start with denial and you know I was
I was just really so inspired by the
book I thought hmm maybe I could have
five five stages to and it actually
worked out well that way um but so that
the second stage is is muddling it's
when everyone is saying okay yeah this
is a problem but they come up with all
sorts of reasons not to do anything
about it and the the stage after that I
call diagnosing but you could also think
of it as that you know blaming or
bargaining from from Elizabeth
kubler-ross it's the what do you do it's
it's making sure you have the right
solution the fourth stage is panic it's
the time when that when the Rhino is
just about on top of you and it's a
double-edged sword on the one hand you
are much more likely to make missteps
you're going to make bad decisions we
see that often in in financial crises
and economic crises where when the
economy is booming nobody wants to cut
the budget nobody wants to be
responsible and it's just on the way
down that I thought they all want to cut
the budget and it actually creates the
snowball effect and things get worse and
worse the final stage is of course
action which is it's it's when you do
something and usually action happens in
such a way that a small group of people
start acting
and you want to create a ripple effect
how do you get these these leaders these
influencers how do you convince other
people that it's in their interest to
actually do something to make the hard
decisions well that's a great transition
to what you and I both said was the
biggest inconvenience true Inconvenient
Truth of all or the the biggest elephant
in the room which is climate change and
the reason I say that is because we're
actually 20 years into the or more to
the diagnosis and so and I remember
taking a course at Harvard in the
nineteen seventies with Roger Revelle
professor Roger Revelle and he was
talking about climate change and the
greenhouse gas effect and so on but here
we are we're actually this year we had
this monumental set of agreements so how
do you see where we are with climate
change and where we go incoming years in
the sort of the scheme of your framework
climate change is a great example of of
all different of five stages at once
that the number of people in denial is
shrink shrinking happily after many
years of very hard work by by many
people you hear modeling you're
diagnosing you know what do you do what
don't we do some of the some of the
diagnosing questions become kind of wild
you know where we're gonna we're gonna
see the clouds we're gonna technology's
gonna magically solve everything I think
some technologies very much can there's
there's one in in the book that just
blew me away in a conversation that I
had moderated in Incheon gin a couple
years ago at the the summer Davos with
with a company that had created
something to literally create plastic
out of thick air I had to Google that
one when I was reading about you like
technologies they basically it's a
carbon capture technology when they put
something on top of the smokestacks is
how I imagined it although I'm sure that
that's not exactly what happens and they
shoot some enzymes at it and it turns
into plastic in fact they being used in
a lot of smart phones so something that
actually takes the carbon out and turns
it into something good and actually
saves whatever carbon might be produced
otherwise in creating the thing that's
that's good you look at some of the
renewable technologies think there are
lots of very very interesting things
going on you know when I was in the
Emirates last October you know they were
doing some very interesting things with
with clean energy and you see a lot of
it across the Middle East now that
they're they're looking at clean energy
technologies I just saw a story a couple
weeks ago about the Morocco and solar
power so there are some things that can
be done but at the same time you still
have huge subsidies of the fossil fuel
industries you're just now seeing the
extent of the the efforts that they've
made to perpetuate denial and we're not
you're not seeing enough of a sense of
the the risks that climate change is
posing to those those companies although
I think that some of the the changes
we've seen in oil prices over the last
year are in some part due to the
changing technologies there's lots of
supply and other factors in that as well
but so you you are seeing action I think
some of the dramatic numbers and facts
that have come out of the last couple
years that the crazy receding of Arctic
ice I mean you look at some of those
maps and you know it reminds me of the
ever bunch painting the stream you know
the highest highest temperatures on
record you see some of these
increasingly violent storms and every
time they happen you get the predictions
of the rising sea levels it's getting
harder and harder and harder to ignore
and the more people are affected
personally by it the more the more
impetus you get for change that said I
you know I think it was amazing that we
finally got the the Paris Accord on
climate change but I don't know anybody
who thinks that it was enough
and I don't know anybody who think it's
thinks that it's going to be implemented
fully and so that's a real cautionary
tale in most cases of action
you see de Leite dollar short that it's
it's never quite as far as it ought to
be right and it seems to me that it
least in my lifetime we've always been
trying to fight a rearguard action
especially when you think about
environmental problems and and related
things like tragedy Commons type issues
but you and you cite a number of
examples in the book about companies
that have taken a leapfrog approach to
starting out fighting a rearguard action
safer an environmental tech problem but
realizing that by addressing it full-on
they leapfrog to new technologies that
make their business more efficient or
change their business model or allow
them to morph completely and and avoid a
gray Rhino of going into obsolescence so
I I was thought about that and in the in
the corporate sectors you'd sort of say
what it takes for that as a group of
CEOs maybe to CEO to CEO to start
talking about these things and start to
share you know their leadership and
they're almost competing with each other
so I was struck by the fact you talked a
little bit about the emergence this last
year or two of China and the u.s.
seeming to say set a long-term agenda
for leadership in climate change is that
potentially analogous to what you see
you've seen in the corporate sectors
where corporations you know Pepsi and
Coke and try to you know I'll do each
other on the sustainability issue and so
on or absolutely you you really have to
see countries working together I have a
friend I've had is right I have all
sorts of arguments with it's kind of a
friend who's fun to argue whether who
might be here tonight but I remember
having an argument with him once about
the SUVs I'm not gonna stop driving my
SUV because no matter what I do China is
building a new coal plant every day and
and there is no point you know this this
helplessness this worrying about what
the the other guy is gonna do is a real
issue so you get countries worried about
competitiveness they're they're worried
about people feeling they're gonna fall
behind and one of the solutions to that
I think
is this this idea of transparency the
and actually one of the things that came
out of Paris was this discussion of okay
you know who's gonna hold countries
accountable for how closely they meet
these targets you know when you count
something it's much much easier to do
something about it I mean it's it really
it really helps but as it becomes harder
and harder to hide risks as it becomes
harder to you know to get away with
doing things you know we've got we've
got social media we've got this digital
outreach we've got people becoming more
and more vocal on these sort of these
things it becomes much harder to avoid
and so that that shining the light of
transparency on what's happening is
incredibly important and you know China
certainly had pressure from outside as
the United States and but there's also
been a lot of pressure from from inside
I mean some of the the videos that were
going around in the protests about
pollution in China were they were heard
you could you could tell they were being
heard so that's another great write-up
from my perspective because I've
invested in China and we invested in
companies that were in the food chain
trying to keep it from being poisoned
dealing with air pollution and water
pollution control but one of the things
we saw in our team saw in the world out
in the secondary cities of China
starting at least five or seven years
ago was that there were huge
demonstrations and disruptions civil of
civil disobedience in effect relating
around environmental concerns way before
there were you know even for the
Tibetans or other things like that in
China very much so one of the interviews
in the in the book is of Peggy Liu who
who helps to promote us Chinese
cooperation on on clean energy and she's
got all of these very elaborate face
masks for the pollution in fact her
facebook profile has it has a picture of
her with the mash you've got a TED talk
where she she wears the masses you know
glue beautifully embroidered and she's
very very passionate about this and says
look you know if you can't you know if
you can't have air that people can
breathe that eventually going to be a
big problem she's she's had to evacuate
her kids
sometimes and she showed me you know she
downloaded the air quality index app
when when I was in China and was was
amazed I think just that being able to
count the air quality index every day
and say something about it is as
important so let me take you through a
couple of big picture foreign policy
concepts and let's talk about how we can
apply a rhino thinking to it and maybe
that'll also be when we open up for
questions of it'll stimulate some of the
issues we might talk about with you but
first of all one interesting thing
Michelle you went to bongani camp where
I went then I took went to Boise many
years ago as well in South Africa and I
have a picture in bongani of our Jeep
literally right behind a rhino walking
down the road and the Rhino is marking
its territory and boy does that stink
they just are there the musk that they
let out so so it seems to me that in
some respect so that sometimes you have
to have some pretty stinky things
associated with the grey rhino situation
and so let me ask you about that we all
remember the concept of ghost wars and
you know effectively by doing a deal
with the devil with with the Afghani
Mujahideen we created Osama bin Laden
and we created the circumstances and I
think policymakers sometimes call that
blowback you know that in covert areas
that's the blowback of our secret CIA
operation but how do we look at that and
there are many examples of that of
course we had to do it a pact with
Hitler and with Stalin did to defeat
Hitler we had you know many many issues
like that in our foreign policy how how
can we look at that it's almost like
they dealing with one big rhino crisis
sometimes you have a baby rhino that
many years later in the next generation
comes back to haunt you very much so and
then sometimes and I see situations like
this right now when you've got clashing
clashing rhinos and you've also got a
situation where people will define their
very very differently Syria you look at
that that you know absolute
quagmire which is one of the types of
rhinos I colleague or D and not you know
in terms of just how hard it is to
unpack I think you have you know Russia
and the United States defining the
nature of the threat and the problem and
the solution in extremely different ways
so that I think tells you how important
it is to try to find ways to align the
key stakeholders in something which is
much much easier said than done I'm not
pretending that it's easy but it's you
know there certainly you know camps were
saying you know Assad is is the problem
you know Assad is the only one who can
bring order those are diametrically
opposed ideas or you look at the debates
over interest rates and and quantitative
easing right now you have the you know
that that the quantitative easing has
led to a number of speculative bubbles
in the markets that have a lot of people
thinking are we going through 2008 again
but then on the other side you have
economic growth which is still you know
that the IMF of numbers that have just
come out are not very cheery so you've
you've got to completely you know
seeming seemingly butting horns butting
heads and I show what their rights sorry
I don't want to get too heavy with with
the metaphors there but deciding what is
the biggest problem and there are times
when you're going to have to trade one
problem for the other you know there's
sometimes you have to say okay this one
I'm gonna let it go your book came to me
I had pre-ordered it from Amazon and
that one just came two days ago but the
one from the publisher came about two
weeks ago and it was right at the time I
went to see the new movie I in the sky
which is about drone drones and the
moral dilemmas of drone usage a stunning
movie for me anyway it was just really
it really hit home but it made me think
a little bit as I was reading your book
okay you know the your concept of grey
rhino is such a rational it's almost
like rational self-interest companies
can you know can use it to see their
rational self-interest and so
but what about making moral judgments as
in I in the sky where the judgment is
okay one collateral damage is perfectly
fine by United States policies and
everything but you get to know this girl
in the movie and you're sitting there in
the movie realizing she's the one
collateral damage of this I you know
this drone strike you are just at the
horns of a dilemma and and how can you
pluck we apply grey rhino thinking
tomorrow issues in other words like that
it's it's very tough at one point in the
in the book I talk about the the trolley
problem you know the the dilemma between
you know that the third you sister
trolley or train that's coming down a
track and it's going to run over six
people and you know question is do you
flip a switch so that it runs over one
person instead of instead of six people
and it's it's that that active behavior
that people have so much trouble with
and like in the movie where there were
gonna be eighty faceless people who were
killed by the bombers but one girl you'd
gotten to know in the movie who would be
killed if they did this strike and and I
just was and and if that speaks so much
to the importance of emotion in
policymaking in in other decision-making
I mean I'm perfectly happy to walk out
with as many you know numbers and
analysis and you know I like the
rational approach to things but I know
rationally that that's irrational
because that's not how people react to
things you know you think about that you
know that the the tragic photo of the
island Kerdi the the little boy on the
on the beach you look at the tremendous
reaction to that and it was it was
really heart rending to see that or you
look at the reactions that people have
to the people who were killed in the in
the terrorist attacks in in Paris and in
Brussels and the tremendous reaction
there and and not as much to deaths of
people the same number of people in
places that
Westerners didn't have as many
connections with or where there were
much more regular attacks that is you
know the more attacks there are the the
more they lose their emotional resonance
and I think it speaks to a real balance
in policymaking you know are these lives
worth more than than those lives it's
not an easy decision at all you've got
you've got constituents to answer to and
I think it says basically that there are
going to be trade-offs and they are
going to be harder to make when there
are emotional decisions to be made you
just I just thought of something you
started out talking about Argentina and
Greece and what's the difference is
there's possibility that it's a little
bit of nationalism or racism involved
here because Greece was at least a
country in our Union that we knew and
Argentina was you know was we the
Western bankers against them in a you
know in a way is there some of that I
think it has to do more with the
interconnections that you know that the
Greece was so tied in with the whole
European ideal and that Argentina was
doing way way down in South America
somewhere perfect set up because what I
wanted to actually get to was he do talk
about that you talk about engagement the
guy's saying that how to grease all with
engagement thing they started and and I
thought about the people my CEO at new
America and Marie slaughter Joan I and
others who have talked about soft power
in foreign policy and in a sense that's
kind of what that's analogous to solving
grey rhino problems i secret to it is
that Juris from all over the world get
together now and talk about cases and
legislators talk about things and you
know all that ties us the United States
more and more into a system we've
facilitated China and other countries
getting into World Trade Organization
and so on and that locks them more into
now China's a reserve currency so
they're locked
or into the world is that is that an
example of gray rhino evolution in
problem-solving gradualism engagement
where the gradualism is is I think it's
important I think it's in some cases the
way that change happens as romantic as
the ideal of a big revolution is I think
it's in in many cases it's it's step by
step but the engagement and the ties you
create very different trade-offs you
create very different emotional
associations and you know it's funny the
title grey I didn't come up with it
intending you know nuance it would but I
think that's a very very good additional
sort of like you know the what is the
icing on the cake it's a it's a way that
the the metaphor works the actual the
grey came from the black rhinos and
white rhinos and when I when I finally
came up with the Rhino image for the
book I was talking to a friend and I was
a rhino and this is only for the finance
world who said we've made a black swan
joke he says oh it's it's a black rhino
and I thought wait a minute there is
such a thing as a black rhino and oh
there is such a thing as a white rhino
do it let me go to Wikipedia I didn't
know anything about very in the book
rhinos they're all great but it's
something so obvious that's right in
front of you and of course the premise
of the Black Swan is you know you you
can't picture a black swan so it doesn't
exist and this was like well you can't
picture the gray Rhino because you're
thinking of the white and the black but
they you know so it's looked about know
what was it that was that a grace one
was called I forget it some bizarre I
there's so much you know it's it's funny
in the in the talk that it that I did at
Davos that helped to build on the idea I
was paired up with William Saeed Oh
who's a fantastic Japanese technology
and crisis management expert and so he
had neon swans mm-hmm so it's you can
have so much fun with this with it with
all the animals but it's actually quite
quite serious and I think that there's a
reason that we that we pick animals that
Aesop's fables have so many powerful
animal images and
my friends teased me my first book was
called by the [ __ ] Fido the rooster the
other rhinos and and it's it's
coincidence but it's not I think that we
can see things and animals that Oh
that help us to see more clearly what
we're doing so maybe we should take a
few questions I would strongly urge
everyone to to read the book it's very
it's it's a lot of fun to read and it's
a lot more detail she's got one whole
page of the for the diagnosing which
kinds of Rhino it is is it a meta Rhino
and as you know I forget what a dead cat
bounce Rhino you really have broken it
down to show you know the different
permutations and how to diagnose and
then that leads to whether how you try
to solve it whether you confront it you
run from it it's a slide out of the way
but do you have anything else you want
to say before we open up or um just add
on that you know diagnosing the kinds I
think of some questions you ask yourself
about I mean that the most important
thing is to start out picking it what
are my top gray rhinos you know whether
it's in your company or in the world I
often say what's your your top Rhino at
work what's your top personal Rhino and
what's your top top grey Rhino in the
world as a citizen on the planet you get
one of each because if you have too many
that it's it becomes very very
complicated you've got to prioritize but
I think in the end the questions you ask
yourself when you're prioritizing which
one to go after you do ask is this is
this something that I know how to solve
do I need to bring in ammunition
ammunition on this is do I know who
needs to be convinced and who who has
come along on the right who's on board
with fixing it how fast is it moving and
the big one is how interconnected is it
to two other gray rhinos and which
direction are those connections I mean
if you have something that's going to
several other things then you want to
prioritize that over one of the one of
the smaller ones and you know it's not
easy there's no silver bullet answer but
I think just starting out asking what's
your gray Rhino gets you on the path
towards towards thinking more clearly
about how to solve the obvious problems
that are in front of you so you give a
couple of examples of countries some of
those oil producers that have tried to
create funds for commodity type funds to
tide over the commodity cycle and most
of the time that the Treasury gets
drained like in Venezuela long before
they actually drawn it for good purposes
but I thought one of the best examples
of gray rhino positive grey rhino
thinking long term was in the last
couple of weeks when Saudi Arabia
announced that they're creating a two
trillion dollar fund to bridge over the
post-oil era for them both in the two
ways one the posterior of revenue from
oil but second of all the energy
transition they will need to make in the
desert and so very much it seemed to me
that was a perfect example very much how
we conducted seminars for the
I think it probably a good idea if he
just gave us your name it briefly an
Thanks she's my lobby from the foreign
policy to decisis great to happen here
Michelle
congratulations on the book it's it's a
great way of looking at the world and
and when you look at you know we're here
in the United States in an election
season and I'd like you to I'd like to
you to reflect on whether you think the
rise of Donald Trump is a gray Rhino or
a Black Swan number and and and number
two what are some of the the biggest
gray rhinos you see here in the United
States sure that's that's a great
question and I can't if I had a nickel
for every time I got it it's it's
something I've been giving a lot of
thought to for me the the idea that a
reality TV star could become you know a
leader in the in the in the primaries
that I think is really a a Black Swan
but the I also very much see him as a
gray rhino but it's I feel like Trump is
the embodiment of several other gray
rhinos that are behind him the
inequality issue which a couple years
ago was top on the World Economic
Forum's Global Risk report list of
global risks and we've we've heard a lot
about it
thomas piketty's you know bestseller on
inequality it's gotten a lot of lip
service but I haven't seen much if any
progress at dealing with it and we've
possibly even gone backwards on that and
you see you see Trump's message you see
Bernie Sanders message you see the rise
of populist movements in the US and
Europe as I think very closely tied to
our failure to address the inequality
gray rhino the other part is what I see
very much as a crisis of agency a
feeling of powerlessness you it's a it's
a theme you hear often among some of the
people interviewed about why they
support Trump why they support Sanders
it's and the way that they're eager to
reach out and embrace someone who says
yeah I'm gonna solve it with great
certainty but little detail is how it's
actually going to happen they
on a certain level it comes back to you
no magical thinking one of the examples
from from the book is from the movie
Mars Attacks which which I loved
it kind of try to be wacky and not
totally serious all the time it's not
easy but it's you know these Martians
come down and they've got their little
Martian fishbowls on their heads and
they're green and they're taking over
the country in the world and they go way
out into the desert somewhere and
there's a little granny listening to the
radio and they're about to come and eat
the granny and this slim pickins song
comes on the radio and it turns out that
that's the magic thing that makes the
little green Martian heads explode
inside the fish balls anyway I have to
go back and watch that I could never get
tired of it but it's this idea of
magical thinking you know someone has a
magical solution which is you know what
points this book is this it's a lot
harder than that
and it's it's not easy so I think the
combination of the the feeling of power
of powerlessness to to influence
government to to make change happen and
that powerlessness is particularly
powerful a Sarah Palin calls it oh well
that hope he change each tough and but
but I think it's true I think when when
Obama came in at the beginning there was
so much enthusiasm and and raised hopes
I looked at that and then I said you
know I've seen this in Latin America
before this charismatic leader comes in
hopes are risen hopes are dashed and
also I think social media is playing
into that in a very interesting way
which we haven't begun to really see the
effect of that you have people come out
they feel like they have a voice on
social media they can they can say
things in certain ways but there's a
disconnect between what people are
saying and what the government is doing
we're at a time when certainly in the
u.s. the government is is paralyzed it's
extremely polarized the you know
primaries are increasingly nasty there's
this just lack of civility and those I
think are are the bigger grey rhinos
I've got you know Trump's like a kind of
baby rhino or you know Rhino with orange
hair or something whatever it's
you know these things are so big and and
heavy and scary and I don't at all want
to make light of them but I also feel
like you need to have some sort of
levity in the discussion you have to
have a way to step back sometimes and
say hey this is not impossible without
being a Pollyanna I think that you need
to be able to say yes there are things
we can do you know you're citing that
issue of politicians sort of giving hope
where there isn't a solution yet don't
forget that's a foreign policy failure
here in this country on two occasions
one Arab Spring I mean Obama went to
Egypt and said it and I remember a
Tunisian friend of mine just last year
when I was there after their their
revolution had been stunned stunted and
and it crushed really you know said you
told us it was okay and you're not there
with us now and and similarly in the
line in the sand in Syria with with
Obama I think people say from following
foreign policy perspective that may have
done more damage to our credibility so
absolutely that's a those are both
examples I think of like letting the
Rhino out before you're ready to solve
the problem just letting it run around
instead of dealing on it
absolutely
hi thank you great connection so I don't
think this is working but it is it is
okay
speaking of sneaky events we are one
week from the anniversary of the Gulf
oil spill sixth anniversary Lord and
stuff and I just did a Huffington Post
vlog on
I'm probably gonna get some rotten
tomatoes thrown at me for saying it's
the begins of the oil spill because I'd
like you to respond to this because in
some ways it's sped up action so I'd
like you to talk about is how your
principles that your you wrote about in
grey rhino how we can speed this up
because what happened with the oil spill
is it increased investment Amin 32% like
right out of the bat everybody went oh
now we're at 329 billion dollars in
investment clean energy we have the
environmental movement got tail winds 37
states four territories now have
renewable energy standards and goals I
mean it was just like bull it was a
hockey stick so we hate it 11 people
lost their lives
you know 600 square miles of gooey crap
on
their science coming out of it research
coming out of it so how do you use a
stinky event to speed up action and
frankly this won't surprise you because
you know me but where does diversity
come in to helping us be better two
issues she does deal with exactly well
one of the points and as I'm certainly
not the first person who's ever said
this but you know a crisis is a terrible
thing to waste
and there are lots of cases in which we
can use a crisis to to create positive
change and that in many cases the
positive change that happens is after a
big messy after that after a Great
Depression you get glass-steagall one of
the chapters of the book is set in in
Calgary after the 2013 floods and
looking at how that was prompting some
resilience measures and some some real
thinking about probably probabilities of
future floods and what to do about it
the the panic stage in the book is is
really a double-edged sword it's either
a place where you make very bad
decisions or it's the time that pushes
action and I'm really glad to see the
the silver lining coming out of of what
happened in the in the Gulf oil spill
you know that said it can be extremely
dangerous to to try to accelerate things
example from from pop culture that's
that's also in the book is Grey's
Anatomy which is one of my favorite TV
shows my sister is completely addicted
but in one of the early seasons there
was a whole plotline around a patient
who had a heart problem if it wasn't bad
enough to get on the transplant list and
but everybody loved him and one of the
interns was in love with him and so she
you know fiddled with the the machines
in such a way that his heart immediately
became bad enough to get up to get
higher on the on the transplant list and
of course because this is a you know
drama soap opera
they had a museum already to have the
surgery but the the surgeon who was
supposed to do it got shot in an attack
and the surgery couldn't happen and so
he died
so that was there's an example of
obviously a made-up example but of how
dangerous it can be to try to push
something forward but at the same time I
think that there are some situations
where there are choices to be made
I mean sometimes people try to muddle
through they try to hide how bad a
situation is and so I think that shining
some light on and letting people see how
bad a situation is it might be a more
benign way of doing that and I think
that we're starting to see more and more
of that with with some of the the ways
that digital media can bring you know
and on the corporate level and well the
Panama papers for example and there's a
way of really saying this is a problem
that's happening that we need to do
something about diversity because you
did diversity yes and diversity you know
it's it's sort of um it's one of things
I call a meta R I know it's it's a
problem that affects other situations
and it goes right back to groupthink and
decision making that if you don't want
to hear about a problem if you don't
want to hear that it exists
you're not going to and you look at the
the very very small numbers of women on
corporate boards in you know as CEOs in
corporate leadership positions and it's
not just women it's anyone with a
different perspective you know the fact
that there's not as much inclusion of
people who can raise red flags women
have very very different talent
tolerances for risk so I think it's it's
it's a huge risk not to have diversity
in the decision-making process and
across companies government's whatever
organizations to not make sure that
there's a way for people to to raise a
red flag
go ahead
Steele it's my first event in science
wonderful thank you very much I wanted
to talk a little bit it seems like this
is a cheat sheet for problem solving
really tough problems and you know it's
it's fact-based it's rational and it
really serves pragmatists you mentioned
a little bit about data you pointed to
your wrist counting steps and the AQI in
China where I spent some time in Beijing
it's pretty rough but whether its
domestic or international I see ideology
and and personal narratives really
obstructing problem solving and so you
know specifically in today's world
I'm millennial but I feel like we're in
undated with data and in Beijing if I
look at the Embassy's a Qi that tends to
be much higher than what the Communist
Chinese party is going to tell you is
the real number
everyone has data but am I looking at
parts per million in 2.5 micrometers or
10 and which one's going to cause cancer
so on so forth how do we start parsing
the data to really achieve consensus
thank you that's a fantastic fantastic
question and I totally I totally agree
with you on on ideology getting in the
way and the you know you look at data
and you go back to Mark Twain and you
know his his ideas about lies darn lies
and statistics and I think finding the
right data and if there's so much data
sorting out data so that you don't just
have a you know a haystack and a needle
there are some people doing very
interesting work on that you know you
know Dana Boyd has got a whole Institute
on data and society I don't pretend to
have the answers to that but one of the
things that I'm really hoping that the
gray Rhino can help do is bring together
people with different areas of expertise
and help them to identify the gray
rhinos you know in their industry in
their field and to work together the the
grey rhino on some levels is is you know
it's very simple it's you know ask
yourself what what the grey rhino is and
everybody's going to have their own take
on that and and I want to that that to
happen I really welcome that I think
it's it's a conversation and it's
something that people can interpret very
very personally and I also actually you
know think that ideology is a it's a
meta gray right now although I'm
somewhat skeptical as to how possible it
is to have absolutely no ideology but
generally you know isms and it's make me
very uncomfortable
even you know on a certain level
pragmatism you know realizing that there
there are limits to that but I think
that people often are not aware enough
of how the little ideological masks
they're wearing color the way they see a
problem and I think being able to ask
yourself ok it were inflation for
example if you if you've got a certain
view on inflation you're not going to
see the the interest rates debates
similarly and I think it's a matter of
asking yourself do you have a goal is
your goal specific and is it is it
measurable is it outcome based or is it
ideological so that's you've raised so
many great points we could have a whole
other the other point about it is the
the business culture for example with
the cigarette debating for so many years
and showing that you know everybody we
just knew that how harmful it was and
yet we all didn't admit it yeah
I think he's gonna microphone coming
thank you for coming it's been such a
wonderful discussion on Karla Freeman
from the Foreign Policy Institute you
alluded to this a couple of times you've
mentioned a leadership in the role of
leaders in in this process including the
audacity of raising hopes how did your
thinking about the grey rhino phenomenon
make you reflect on leadership and what
it means to be a good or effective
leader that's a great question I love
that one of the conclusions was was not
a very happy one unfortunately but it's
it's really that leadership sometimes
means you know being aware that you're
going to take a fall before doing the
right thing Joan of Arc you know saves
France from English gets burned at the
stake yay
you know that you're not always going to
that you're not always going to get
credit for things another part of it
really has to do with with listening it
goes back to the decision-making and
diversity part of the conversation it's
been very interesting at a couple of
talks that I've given people have said
and I've spoken both you know in a very
high-level groups but also to of people
who are getting their job done and they
said what when we see a problem what can
we do to make sure that the people up
top with the power to yeah allow change
to happen how do we get them on board
with it and and that's a very different
one but it's it speaks to leadership
really being the ability to hear things
that you don't want to hear to hear
things from a broad set of people from
all different levels in the company from
all different perspectives and I think
of you know of not considering yourself
to be infallible is it very much is
about about leadership but you know
leader being willing to say this
this is big this is in front of me and I
don't have a handle on it
why this thinking so if I sort of play
devil's advocate and look at some of the
things that we've talked about before we
have this question that we identify as
one or many huge problems that we know
are coming and then we have to decide
whether we're going to act or not but my
question is what if we act what if we
act too soon right I mean look at the
case for example Germany the and even
though right I mean they spend a huge
amount of money trying to fight climate
change and if they'd waited a little bit
it would have been a lot cheaper same
with the with the the question of the
carbon capture I mean when it becomes a
crisis it becomes cheaper to respond to
the crisis in some ways at least at
least psychologically so I guess again
from the devil's advocate perspective
how do we know if we're addressing gray
rhinos because because we feel like we
shouldn't how do we know if we're
actually ignoring them because there are
more pertinent things right now it's
it's a great question and it goes along
side with the you know how do you know
if you're you know dealing with you know
with with a threat just because it's
there how do you sort them out how do
you prioritize and obviously there's no
easy answer and certainly not one that
fits in between the the covers of the
book one of the things I was trying to
do was harness some of the intellectual
energy that the Black Swan did I just I
looked at so many people going oh
there's a Black Swan I mean if you do an
I don't even know what the the Nexus
search count would be or the Google
search for how many mentions of Black
Swan and even though people were a
little misguided in their interpretation
of it I just felt the focus was in the
wrong place there are not easy answers I
don't pretend to say that there are in
terms of costs of responding there's a
bit of a paradox in in sort of you know
financial terms or you know energy
whatever measure you want to use it
often is much more expensive to respond
at the last minute your options
generally narrow quite dramatically
judith Roden and a lot of her work on
resilience has showed quite extensively
how much
return you get if you invest in
prevention in resilience its avoided
costs which we don't account for
properly but you know for example when I
went to to Minnesota to the the memorial
for the bridge that had collapsed there
I looked and I don't have the exact
numbers on top of my head but there in
the book on how much more it costs to
rebuild the bridge quickly on no notice
plus the cost in lives plus the the loss
commuting times the lost business all of
that and it's a problem that's common to
infrastructure you I think there's
something like 80,000 bridges that need
to be fixed and it becomes this this
long term versus short term cost
calculation saying hey I'm sorry we
don't have any money in the budget right
now to deal with this we've got to deal
with this other much more urgent thing
and then of course when something falls
apart because you haven't dealt with it
early on then that only creates more of
a vicious spiral and so I think we need
to think somewhat differently about how
we account for things in policymaking to
look harder at avoided costs the other
question is that when there's a crisis
there some how often are these magical
pools of money from you know federal
disaster funds and blah blah blah what
if we were to instead you know shrink
the federal disaster fund pool and
reallocate some of that towards towards
prevention and and with with aid in
other countries as well Steven Covey has
this this really great tool out of the
seven Habits of Highly Effective leaders
which he he has this little grid you
know is this urgent and this is this
important and he points out how much
time we spend in the urgent category
whether or not it's important and so
there are some things I think that you
do need to just let go so you know what
this is this is it you know in business
sometimes that's called creative
destruction and it can be a very good
thing you you want to cushion the people
who are affected by it as much as you
can
but find ways to allocate more time more
budget more energy more priority
whatever to the things that are
important but not necessarily immediate
and I think we could do a lot better at
every level from from policymaking at
the global to the national to the
regional and local level to businesses
to you know to personal life frankly I
mean one of the great minds that comes
up all the time is is retirement
planning or you know saving for college
you know there are all sorts of things
that are very relevant on a personal
level and you know obviously those
aren't the big giant things that affect
everyone but but for an individual who's
affected it's it's pretty darn important
so I think you you can be flexible in
your definition there but if someone who
invests in the areas that you're talking
about one of the ways I've had to
reconcile this for many years is to
argue that you don't go off and just try
to invent whole new technologies
immediately that leads to Solyndra
problems and all kinds of crazy things
especially when politicians do it you do
the things that are cost effective from
a capital allotment set we know right
away energy efficiency pricing all these
things you buy time you don't turn off
the nuclear power plants today because
they've got twenty more years of to run
and in the mean that's 20% of the
electricity in the country even if you
don't like nuclear power you don't you
know Al Gore I'm sorry you can't do that
but if you do by 20 or 40 more years
what matters to you - for climate change
is where we are technologically in 2050
not not somehow doing it immediately
today and by the way our renewable
energy program I had the the
transmission guys from from Germany come
in ten years ago now saying we've put
twenty five thousand megawatts of wind
North Sea wind in place we spent more
money than you can imagine and now and
we can't even say it's greenhouse gas
positive because we have so much standby
generation diesel-powered that we have
to keep in Germany to meet peak load
when the wind isn't blowing so so
policymakers often
don't weren't gray rhinos solvers in the
way that Michelle's talking about you
know parse it look at the long term
you've got 20 30 40 years for your
technology side so put in a good program
like like Saudi Arabia is doing with
their two trillion dollar facility for
example
the pressure of that policy
to take care of their own neighborhood
so you've got that that pressure coming
up pork-barrel yeah
no problem but I don't think you were
talking about the same kind of gray
right very much so
you know I think there are there are
situations where you've got to say you
know what this is just not worth not
worth fighting look an example from the
corporate world Kodak invented the
digital camera and they decided not to
run with it because they were afraid
that they were going to cannibalize
their existing technologies and didn't
work out real well for them but you know
the other thing I should when I was in
Minnesota I was I was amazed that the
bridge Memorial was right near the mill
the mill museum and all these old flour
mills in the area and they were just all
there and of course when you know when
the mills switched from water power to
the java source of energy they could be
they could be anywhere and so I think
there are a lot of energy of industries
that you know they become obsolete that
fall aside because there's something
better and it's important to realize
when that is you know when is something
fighting a losing battle when just
something fall aside and let something
better come by and it goes back to
actually one of the big points in the
book which is how do you turn a threat
into an opportunity you know a very
common one for many companies is the
question of succession and in control
you'll have people saying hey this is
this is it the the in the older
management doesn't want to recognize
that it's time for for newer energies to
come in so there's there definitely
times when the right thing to do is that
all right trample me
put me on an iceberg well I want to
thank everyone I think we can Michele's
willing to stick around and answer a few
questions but this is great I want to
thank sice for hosting this and thank
Michelle for writing the book to give me
an opportunity to spend this time
[Applause]